on m'a semblé le test
j'appelle sophie soulignac leilat el
hiba sens
valet
bienvenue à amos yadlin 9 ce soir 1
c'est cool quand il lâche t il à stybar
est d'accord à 100 on est content et que
des chanteurs ch'tis qui va adorer
alors tout est dit ou fait star mag tous
les jours à 19h55 sur tps star
ça consiste en quoi sophie c'est une
heure d'émission de cinéma je voudrais
jour avec une bande de jeunes qui adore
le cinéma qui essaye de transmettre leur
enthousiasme en allant voir plein de
films ce qui est même un boulot très
difficile pour connaître des tiac en
effet la wii vous avez qui comme star
dans votre émission là beaucoup de ménez
obtient coppola audrey tautou beyoncé
noces terry fox tout va bien on a vu
dany boon
ah bah quand même vous attendez on a
gardé le meilleur pour la fin
vous l'avez vu son film bien sûr pas mal
bah je ferai plus jamais de travaux chez
moi mais à part l on va bien alors vous
mettre les dix j'appelle jérôme foucault
à
du lourd un euro le murano d'urban
without you know de murano laurine du
secondaire tu connais toi oui ces dates
mignonne celle des riches
bon oui tu as raison
eh bien on sait qu'on sait si elle va
être diffusé pour la chaîne de heurter
un fils bien tu es prêt jérôme on y va
voilà vous connaissez le principe
d'abord c'est l'équipe de jacno contre
l'équipe de nolwenn h et responsable
eelv au maire responsable de quelque
chose une fois dans ta vie responsable
de vos d'énormément de choses de vie
mais là du blind test c'est un peu dur
quand même tu pas voilà c'est ton équipe
voilà et donc les titres de nolwenn
attention mais ses peines il a été avec
nolwenn giro
elle pas venu pour perdre un talent et
bien ça fait un point pour l'équipe de
nolwenn évidemment numéro 2 0
non
ce nettoyeur
vraiment
non
quincy jones
bravo si l'on continue géo amie jenny
bas
at il dit
bon alors ça fait quoi rêver car et
qu'est-ce qu'on a emballé la dessus à
l'époque on appelait ça fait deux points
pour l'équipe de nolwenn quand même
maïwenn a gagné la star ac avait pas à
l'abri de gagner ce blind test vous
allez voir mais en quatre
mais non
et dany tu la communauté est marrante
qui allaient génial
ok on continue geo non madame il
pour qu'ils trouvent
non c'est le boulot qui connait barry
manilow copacabana lent alors vous en
êtes tous là à
on y va c'est normal elle est en
afghanistan tout le temps je vais à
l'express et par ok folk mais vous la
soulignac ma vie ce qui fait danser ton
métier toiture il faudrait cinéma chum
où nos neurones
l'usiné
l'union musicale
charden
non c'est bien parce que j'ai entendu
enfin j'ai honte d'avoir trouvé pourquoi
non pas les dire laurent laurent pas dit
non non c'est pas dire ouais ça puisse
du mas dieu toi souchon et voulzy parce
qu'il avait fait une parodie de cette
chance avait sébastien c'est pour ça je
devais concept 8-7 et gi joe
avant guingamp
oui
1 ces champs sont les paroles sont nuls
mais moi je dis c'est trois points en
plus c'est un sable cette performance
fifa j'ai dit laurent blanc manteau lait
big m
voilà
le second
qu'est ce que c'est bon un très bon
rythme à quel rythme jo
et les prix
5 pour nolwenn trois projets qui n'ont
aucun sens
diane bernage attention attention
szabolcs ce n'est qu'une tricherie enfin
c'est patrice richard hannon
ouais mais bon le temps la triche à la
star ac' là les clean
on continue jérôme
non
ali
c'est un regard bouteille reconnaît on
goûtera d'économie fesci rapide moi
j'avais reconnu ici mais ça aussi vite
que s'habille comme elle aussi de
qualité ce qui fait des vannes dans la
fulgurance et il trouve les échanges
sont les blind test sur les impros voilà
reste plus 80 du paraguay lettre de
recommandation
c'est assez précis c'était assez précis
comme savoir faire mais il peut trouver
il ya des télés en afghanistan et non
est en arabie saoudite il peut trouver
bien sûr en burqa est aussi notre job
list
je conseille aux jeunes générations cet
album what will i am going home qui
durant deux minutes 35 je conseille ça
aux oreilles aller maintenant
ouais vous y allez marine et du need you
made man en prison encore un petit bout
non scellées difficile
non
bien on continue jérôme il
g
l'original était de ouais bravo bravo
bravo
ouais c'est de la musique de michel jo
j'ai froid
là
les mettre sur mon i pod les stray cats
je sais pas cela c'est bien ou bien
allez c'est magnifique c'est vrai et
après tu te fais toi oui oui puis je me
fais là voilà donc à l'issue du par
équipes c'est l'équipe de nolwenn qui
gagne avec une jauge
alors
soit dans d'autres pays situé aussi
alors messieurs du par équipes c'est la
fin du paris dès maintenant chacun pour
sa gueule chocolat pour sa gueule je
vais vous étonner c'est le libéralisme
voilà j'ai plus d'amis attention on y va
le bon goût jérôme robbie williams non
oh non le noir
ouais
exact mais la raison c'est la trop de
robbie williams eut peut remettre un
trophée qu'elle a réservé un est la
raison l'a bien pompé au but s'est servi
des gangs et bravo au qatar ouais fumier
bien bien vu bienvenue nolwenn alors on
continue
c'était le bon coup on passe au super
banco attention gérault
jouer
seuls groupes anglo-saxons qui chante en
ch'ti ouais alors maintenant on passe à
l'ultra banco c'est très très très très
difficile c'est un groupe que j'adore
personnellement mais bon peut-être
suis-je le seul en attentions se
concentrent tous mais c'est vrai que tu
trouve toi ça va tomber les années 80
cette merde là ouais exactement ils sont
venus à lunettes noires pour nuits
blanches
depeche mode and on attend il condamne
pas la chanson par jacques attention
mais tu peux trouver toi allons-y jérôme
sebag
j'ai peur
ma nation
madeleine
allez c'est tout avait si la caméra le
cadreur et la légère
retour nathan classe thierry barba il
retourne à sa place à meuh non ils
allaient me jean lors du groupe d'abord
c'est christophe flotte bourbon
et
elle est aussi une chanson géniale
s'appelait manhattan de prefab sprout et
kings love rock'n'roll c'est vraiment un
très bon groupe bien de nos colis su
alors rebecca qui a gagné c'est thierry
normand
voilà